if you want to see how a keys are hidden
in several shots throughout the movie
then stick around to the end of this
video 2009 it was the end of the decade
Amiga he goes the biggest youtuber with
less than two million subscribers all
the great wonderful reasons why 2009
suck platypus and a comedy horror called
zombie Lana became the darling of pop
culture in an October noticeably void of
many horror movies
sounds familiar let's get in to the
things you missed the film opens by
showing zombies at the US Capitol
building in Washington DC something that
looks like it may be revisited in the
sequel and after a zoom out you can see
some of the Ryan's at Pacific island
which the characters would visit at the
end of the movie as Columbus is going
over the rules he mentions an
interesting observation when you're at
your most vulnerable somehow they could
just smell it this could explain why so
many of them gather at the end of the
movie outside of the fact that Wichita
Littlerock are already drawing extra
attention to themselves by turning on
the theme park the opening credits are
animated to react to each of the scenes
and the directors credit Ruben Fleischer
gets jumbled around so that it reads
Ruben flash you know because zombies eat
flesh Tallahassee paints the number
three on both of his cars this is
probably a tribute to American racecar
driver Dale Earnhardt which uses the
number three and can be seen on a poster
intel has his flashback Columbus never
makes it back to Ohio to see if his
parents are still alive but he does
mention that they're also paranoid
shut-ins much like himself maybe there's
a hint that they are still alive for the
sequel
during his flashback I noticed a very
nice piece of Aqua Teen Hunger Force art
on the wall probably a sign of things to
come because hunger is the main force
that drives not only the zombies but
also tallahassee columbus also drinks
can after can of Mountain Dew Code Red
Code Red is usually a term used to
describe a state of emergency which
could be an accurate way to label the
zombie outbreak seen in this movie
Columbus and his hot neighbor call each
other by their apartment numbers which
keeps up the trend of there being no
real names used for most of his movie
when she turns into a zombie and comes
after him to the bathroom the subtle
jokers that he sprays her with
disinfectant spray zombies are often
calls to the infected so it's kind of
funny to think that something like that
would work the Twinkie search takes
Columbus in Tallahassee to Blaine's
grocery a name that was later used in
the 2013 Samba survival game called
state of decay Wichita and Little Rock
scheme is to make the boys think that
Little Rock is infected in order for
Wichita to do the honors on our sister
only to steal the guns in the vehicle
it's a pretty risky plan if you ask me I
mean how did they not know that
Tallahassee wouldn't just fire without
hesitation right about here
Tallahassee's longing for a Twinkie
continues after the guys lose all of
their stuff leave it or not
Twinkies have an expiration date this is
a reference to a well-travelled myth
that Twinkies never expired but in
reality they last about 25 days if
Tallahassee is aware of this fact then
that means almost all of North America
was wiped out in a little under one
month it's amazing how quickly things
can go from bad to total storm when
Columbus in Tallahassee make it to the
next town a couple of upside-down
American flags can be seen this could be
somewhat of a new flag for zombie land
because we also see an inverted
star-spangled banner in the opening shot
of the movie there's also some humorous
stuff hidden in the background of the
town seem like a bridal shop plastered
with anti zombie propaganda and one
store with a no zombie sign as if saying
that they aren't allowed in would
somehow protect them maybe the owners of
that store make sup zombies with the
vampires I'll come back to analyze the
car scene later in this video but I've
got to point out they waste a lot of
ammo in this movie
in the scene that shows one of Wichita
and Little Rock's pre Zombieland scams
this gas station employee is the same
guy from the beware of bathrooms example
scene two minutes into the movie poor
dude just can't catch a break there's
also a gag that appears a couple of
times where the characters referenced
something called zombie kill of the week
zombie kill of the week no it comes up
again later when they gets the Indian
Trading Post zombie kill week close but
no cigar
zombie kill of the week goes to sister
Cynthia Knickerbocker
I don't know how Columbus would have
known about this I mean I'm pretty sure
that there's no TV or Internet at this
point
apparently the idea for zombie killer of
the week is actually left over from when
the script for zombie land was actually
being considered as a weekly TV show
rather than a movie but let's say they
do know about Cynthia Knickerbocker that
would help explain this line later on
from Tallahassee
so Columbus Tallahassee Bill Murray
Wichita Little Rock and Cynthia
Knickerbocker are the six people left as
far as we know their next stop is at
this Native American gift shop place a
location stuffed with even more hidden
meanings and things you missed
at the Trading Post and okay I wouldn't
normally point out something this a
random but this hat is the same hat that
Jesse wears in Toy Story 2 I mean it's
the exact same hat that's the only
reason I bring it up and this scene
represents the white man's conquest to
take over in control America and the
destruction it caused to Native American
communities in the blatant disregard for
Indian culture on their journey to
commit mass genocide now I'm just
kidding this is just a fun scene where
they break stuff also kemo sabe the name
of the place that they stopped off in is
a phrase used by Tonto in the classic
western television series The Lone
Ranger which oddly enough has come up in
two consecutive things you missed
episodes hi-ho silver rolls
y-you-you Kemosabe
kemo sabe Suns from lizard that's right
Kemosabe you testy Scout trusty years
gone so naming this location Kemosabe
fits in perfectly with the themes of
zombie land at the beginning there each
rogue Scouts but in order to thrive each
of them has to learn to trust each other
Kemosabe a trusty Scouts their next
destination is Hollywood where they stay
at Bill Murray's house and one night
they discuss what the best parts of
zombie land are best thing about Zeeland
no no Facebook status updates you know
Rob Curtis is gearing up for Friday the
actor that plays Columbus is named Jesse
Eisenberg and less than one year later
he would play Facebook founder Mark
Zuckerberg in the David Fincher movie
The Social Network the social network
was casted in summer of 2009 a bit after
Zombieland was shot in February 2009
however both were produced by Columbia
Pictures and distributed by Sony so it's
possible that when zombie land was
created they had the inside scoop that
Eisenberg was probably gonna play
Zuckerberg and put in that joke because
it isn't all that funny without the
context but like the discussion about
the best parts of zombie land it's the
character relationship scenes that make
this movie stand out above many other
zombie flicks like the romantic scene
between Columbus and Wichita they
discuss what each of them was doing in
1997 what was I doing in nineteen
I guess that would have been in pre-k
Wichita says that she saw her first
r-rated movie in 97 ironically my first
r-rated movie came out in 1997 as well I
didn't see it in 1997 obviously but we
do kind of have that in common
when wichita tells about her first kiss
columbus Astor you guys this may be
because he's still a little bit
traumatized about what happened last
time he had a crush on a girl
[Music]
yeah so the girls leave Bill Murray's
house the next morning and by the way I
find it a little hard to believe that
bill doesn't have any Cubs memorabilia I
mean they just had come off to Division
titles at the time anyway the girls go
to the theme park and turn on the power
and I love how the riders just
immediately start going like as soon as
the power goes on all the rides just
start running or something like
something out of a theme park
creepypasta at the end of the movie
Tallahassee does finally get his Twinkie
however there are four Twinkies that he
overlooked over the course of the
adventure the first was when they come
across the crashed hostess truck but
it's filled with snowballs
but if Tallahassee had looks just a
little bit further he would have found a
bunch of Twinkies stashed behind the
other door of the truck then in the
grocery store he walks right past the
Twinkies while he's taking out this
zombie just kidding if any of you have
seen this image it's actually
photoshopped it's not real and finally
in the snack shack moments after
Columbus blows the bullet shell through
the last remaining box of Twinkies
Tallahassee turns on the lights the
storage pantry not sure how he knew
where the light switch was but he
somehow overlooks the Twinkies sitting
on the shelf but there's one more long
yellow tree it filled with a sweet
filling and that comes just after
Tallahassee loses his car to Wichita on
Little Rock the Hummer the Hummer is
truly Tallahassee's Twinkie that he
never knew he wanted the yellow metal
covering on the outside offers in
protection that he needs to survive in
Zombieland
and the sweet filling is the guns that
they find in the backseat which give
them a much needed means of fighting
back against the zombies the happiest we
see Tallahassee other than when he beats
Bill Murray is when he gets his two
Twinkies something about a Twinkie
reminded him of a time not so long ago
when things were simple and not so
[ __ ] psychotic
it was like if you got a taste of that
comforting childhood treat the world
would become innocent again and
everything would return to normal and so
it does when these four survivors put
away their trust issues to become sort
of like a family but do they stay that
way we'll find out in Zombieland too and
you'll find out some of the things you
missed in next week's episode so make
sure you subscribe to see these world's
four new Horrors every week ring that
death bell for notifications and I'll
see you in the next one assuming we both
survive
[Music]